هل يمكنني أن أبدأ بسؤالك ما
هو رأيك فيما إذا كانت حكومتك وجيشك
قد قام بعمل جيد بما فيه الكفاية
لإثبات ادعائهم بوجود
مركز قيادة رئيسي ومخبأ تحت
ألفا أه، إنه أه، إنه معروف بالفعل منذ
سنوات عديدة أنهم  في البنوك
التي بنتها في الأصل
بنايات إسرائيلية تحت الشفاء كانت
تستخدم كمركز قيادة أه لحماس
ونوع من ملتقى
عدة أنفاق أه جزء من النظام
لا أعرف أقول إلى أي مدى  هو
رائد ربما ليس هو
النوع الوحيد من مراكز القيادة التي
توجد تحت مستشفيات أخرى أو في أماكن أخرى أه
حساسة ولكن من المؤكد أنه تم
استخدامه من قبل أه من قبل حماس حتى أثناء
هذا أه الصراع حسنًا عندما تقول أنه
تم بناؤه من قبل إسرائيل  هل
أخطأت أيها المهندسون، لا، لا، بعض ما تعرفه منذ عقود مضت،
كنا ندير المكان، لذلك احتفظنا
بهم منذ عقود عديدة منذ
خمسة أو أربعة عقود مضت، حيث
ساعدناهم في بناء هؤلاء المصرفيين من
أجل تمكين أه المزيد أم
مساحة أكبر ل  تشغيل المستشفى
ضمن الحجم المحدود للغاية لهذا
المجمع، حسنًا، حسنًا، هذا هو ما
أزعجني
قليلاً، لذلك كانت هذه الأشياء موجودة لفترة
طويلة ولكنك تدعي أو هم
يدّعون ذلك  يتم استخدامهم
كمركز قيادة رئيسي على أي حال، حقيقة
الأمر هي أنهم
لم يظهروا حتى الآن دليلاً قاطعًا على ذلك،
لذا هل لي أن أسألك ما الذي تفعله أيها المسيحي المسيحي،
انتظر لحظة، ليس الأمر
سهلاً، نحن نحرص على ذلك  لإلحاق الضرر
بتشغيل المستشفى، لذلك حذرنا
لعدة أيام من أننا سنأتي إلى
هناك، ثم اقتربنا بحذر شديد
لتجنب خسارة
الأرواح بين الأطباء والمرضى
أو الممرضات هناك نتيجة لذلك.
كان لدى كاماس كل الوقت في
العالم لمحاولة تنظيفه ومحاولة محوه ومحاولة
جعله أقل
وضوحًا عندما ندرك أنه كان قيد
الاستخدام ولكننا واثقون من أنني لا أستطيع الخوض
في كل المعلومات الاستخبارية التي لديك  نحن على
ثقة من أنه يتم استخدامه منذ سنوات
كنوع من المراكز الرئيسية أو غير الرئيسية
ولكن كمركز قيادة
لأنشطة كاش في الجزء الشمالي من
شارع غزة